we're told that we want to factor the
following expression that they have
right here and they say that we can
factor the expression as u plus V
squared where u and V are either
constant integers or single variable
expressions
what are u and V and then they ask us to
actually factor the expression so pause
this video and see if you can work on
that alright so let's go with the first
part of it so they say they can factor
the expression as u plus V squared so
how do we see this expression in terms
of U plus V squared well one way is to
just remind ourselves what u plus v
squared
even is u plus V squared this is just
going to be a the square of a binomial
and we've seen this in many many other
videos this is going to be u squared
plus two times the product of these two
terms
so 2 u v plus V squared if you've never
seen this before not sure where this
came from
I encourage you to watch some of those
early videos where we explain this out
but does this match this pattern well
can we express this term as u squared
well if this is U squared then you would
have to be equal to X plus 7 and when I
say actually let me be a little careful
can we express this entire thing right
over here as u squared if u squared is
equal to X plus 7 squared that means
that U is going to be equal to X plus 7
and then this right over here would have
to be V squared if this is V squared
then that means that V is equal to Y
squared because Y squared squared is
equal to Y to the fourth so V is equal
to Y squared now they already told us
that this this this can be factored as
the expression u plus V squared but
let's make sure that this actually works
is this middle term right over here is
this truly equal to 2 times u times V to
U V well let's see 2 times u would be 2
times X plus 7 times V times y squared
and that's exactly what we have right
over here it's 2y squared times
so X plus 7 so this kind of hairy
looking expression actually does fit
this pattern right over here so you can
view it as au plus V squared where u is
equal to X plus 7 and V is equal to Y
squared now using that we can out
actually factor the expression we can
write this thing as being equal to u
plus V squared and we know what U and V
are so this is this whole expression is
going to be equal to u which is X plus 7
and I'll put in parentheses just so you
see it very clearly plus V plus y
squared squared because that's exactly
what we wrote over there and of course
you don't have to write these
parentheses you could rewrite this as X
plus 7 plus y squared squared let's do
another example so here once again we
are told that we want to factor the
following expression and they're saying
that we can factor the expression as u
plus V times u minus V where u and V are
either constant integers or single
variable expressions so pause this video
and try to figure out what U and V are
and then actually factor the expression
all right well let's just remind
ourselves in general what u plus V times
u minus V is equal to well if this is
unfamiliar to you I encourage you to
watch the videos on difference of
squares but when you multiply this all
out this is going to give you a
difference of squares u squared minus V
squared if you actually take the trouble
of multiplying this out you're going to
see that that middle term that middle
third terms or the middle terms I should
say cancel out so you're just left with
the u squared minus the V squared and so
does this fit this pattern well in order
for this to be U squared
and for this to be V squared that means
U squared is equal to 4x squared so that
means that you would have to be equal to
the square root of that which would be 2
times X notice U squared would be 2x
squared which is 4x squared and then V
would have to be equal to the square
root of 9 Y to the 6 with the square
root of 9 is 3 and the square root of Y
to the 6 is going to be Y
to the third power and then we could use
that to factor the expression because we
could say hey this right over here is
the same thing as u squared minus V
squared so it's going to be equal to we
can factor it out as or factor it as u
minus or u plus V times u minus V so
what's that going to be equal to so u
plus V is going to be equal to 2x plus
3y to the third and then u minus V is
going to be equal to 2x which is our u
right over here minus RV minus 3y to the
third so there you had it we factored
the expression then you might want to
write it down here but we just did it
right up there and we're done